and in terms of like looking at the idea
itself yeah what would be if you had two
ideas what would you look and in terms
of this is a better idea than the other
idea for me it changes I don't think I
can just say you know this idea or that
idea I think one of the things I really
look for is someone building a product
or a product or a company that's focused
on a market that's growing or that will
grow because that product exists I don't
really love products that are entering
super mature markets because at that
point startups lose a lot of their you
know a lot of their nimbleness and a lot
of their advantages because if you're
going into a mature market basically
what gets you noticed is advertising
dollars right and you're just fighting
for a slice of a pre-existing pie but if
you build something that's gonna cause a
market to grow or building something for
mark that is growing you're fighting for
a slice of an ever-expanding pie and
that is so much more interesting
it lets you play around more the rules
aren't written there's all these things
you can do so I like those kinds of
things more but that's not to say that
there aren't great businesses to be
built in mature markets as well and it
also depends on how you think about
what's a mature market what's not and
then I also like like companies that
make me think honestly that make me look
at a problem from a brand new
perspective something that makes me say
huh I didn't realize you could do that
very cool you know that's and that's
tough to do right because we spend all
day thinking about ideas and thinking
about new companies but when you see one
of those that's the kind of thing that
you get really excited about so what
would be an example of a early-stage
market you notice is a mature markets so
mature market and this is kind of a
silly example but junk food or something
like that it's like a pretty mature
market right so if company came to us
and said I'm gonna make a new kind of
potato chip now there's a bunch of
reasons we probably wouldn't fund it but
one of the things there's like I hide
its potato chips what more can you do
now you look at the last 10 years and
we'll look at
Engels right they built a really big
company I think I actually don't know
how big they are
you know they built a big company but
primarily a marketing challenge you know
in software there's some things that are
also mature market so CRM right customer
relationship management software it's
actually a pretty mature market now
Salesforce disrupted it in a lot of ways
to build a very large company and
there's still things that can be done
but it takes something really insightful
and really new to figure out how to
build the next great CRM company and I
think there will be more of them it's
just a lot harder so not to say it's a
bad idea but it takes a little more
thinking and a little more a lot I think
a much deeper insight you know some
newer markets that that are really
immature one that I that I like to think
about drones drones you know drew
everyone likes to talk about them but I
think it was something like 500 thousand
drones were sold last year and the
markets growing by some ridiculous
percentage every single year that is
such an underdeveloped market and when
you think about all the applications
that drones have yet to touch it's kind
of on mind-boggling I mean we're talking
everything from crop analysis right
flying a drone over a field which they
typically do a fixed-wing aircraft now
just to see how healthy crops are all
the way to tracking shots and movies you
know there's kind of like all these
things and we don't know what that's
going to do not to mention you know
unmanned drones giving the Internet to
places which you know Facebook and
Google are both working on or
transporting people right I don't know
that's gonna be cool it's gonna be
really cool